okay question for eric what are the best
ways to do
um concurrent cardio so low intensity
training or high intensity training
along with lifting yeah so i've got a
brief anecdote about this
i was in finland and i was talking about
bodybuilding
contest preparation from a research
perspective
and uh i didn't really
study up on the event too much before i
went there i knew what i was going to do
i knew the general context and i was
like perfect
and i got there the first day and i was
like
i probably should have considered the
fact that uh professor haakenan
was there as was uh yuha atienen
and so like most of the really good
concurrent training research for the
last like
ever basically came out out of their lab
and i was like oh god i have some slides
on concurrent training
i was like this is not my bread and
butter like but it seemed prudent when
you're talking about bodybuilders who
are lifting
and doing a ton of cardio a lot of times
so i was
really really scared because they were
in the audience i was like i hope they
agree with me because if not
then i'm clearly wrong you know like
yeah i'm not gonna argue with them
um but in any case uh
as i presented my slides they smiled and
nodded the whole time so that was a good
sign
someone else at the event also did a
talk specifically about concurrent
training
and all of our general recommendations
lined up quite well so i walked away
feeling very good about myself
now when it comes to concurrent training
uh there's a really nice review uh by an
author the last name is
i'm gonna it's gonna sound like a
disease when i say this that's clearly
not how you pronounce it
to me it looks like methanitis that's
how it looks to me too okay
uh but it came out in 2018 very nice
review
um talking about concurrent training
obviously
there is some potential to experience an
interference effect and that is
if you're doing a ton of aerobic
training and a ton of resistance
training
um the signaling pathways that that
precede adaptations in the muscle to
each of these types of training
they are to some extent at odds with
each other
and we do see um as i kind of talked
about in my presentation in finland
nervously when you see interventions
where people
are doing a ton of cardio and a ton of
lifting
you do tend to see an interference
effect present
but when they start getting a little bit
more careful about the overall volume of
both
those are the interventions where you
really don't see much of a pronounced
interference effect
and so there are things you can do when
it comes to intensity volume and timing
that very much reduce the likelihood of
a significant interference effect
can i just throw one thing in here yes
so most most people listening to this
are pr probably either primarily have
hypertrophy or strength goals the other
aspect of the interference effect that's
not talked about quite as often
is the impact of concurrent training
versus resistance training alone on
power output
or like high velocity stuff and
the literature as far as uh like
strength and hypertrophy goes
does show that yeah you can mess with
some of these variables
and either negate the interference
effect or at least minimize it
pretty substantially the stuff on power
output
is a little bit more dire um the
interference effect is larger it shows
much larger
way way larger it shows up in more
context
etc so like if you're just trying to
build big legs
or improve your squat and you want to do
some cardio like
yeah you'll probably be fine uh if you
take the advice that eric's about to
give
but if you know if you're trying to put
four inches on your vertical
probably not the best idea yeah that's a
really good point um
it's pretty wild when you see the drop
in power in some of those studies
with the interference effect or just the
lack of power adaptations that take
place
power is usually more effective than
strength and strength is usually a
little more effective than hypertrophy
generally speaking so i'm of the opinion
that hypertrophy is the only thing that
actually matters
and so that that's why my answer is
written from that perspective
um so with all these things
you know power is tricky but if you
really want to include cardio and you
really want to avoid
the interference effect the first thing
you want to do
is be really cautious about how much of
both you're doing
and so like the thing i brought up in my
slides about uh
physique athletes is like you'll see
competitors in case studies and it's
like they were lifting
90 minutes a day six days a week and
they were doing at least four hours of
cardio a week
that's a lot that and their oh by the
way they're also eating at an enormous
deficit like
they're interfering all over the place
but that's kind of the nature of the
game but um
something that you can do is try to you
know
limit the number of times per week that
you're doing
what i would call a real aerobic bout of
exercise if you're taking a 30 minute
walk just to get your energy expenditure
up
i don't consider that part of the game
here we're talking about something where
you're
jogging or more in terms of intensity in
my opinion
or you know getting on the bike and
doing some real dedicated pedaling
a walk around the neighborhood i think
you could probably do that to your
heart's content
assuming it's not an outrageous number
of hours you're spending doing that per
day
you're probably not going to interfere
with much at all in my opinion
um now
i i would say the more you can limit
your cardio sessions certainly the more
you can limit the interference effect
the tricky thing is a lot of times
people will say
try to prefer high intensity intervals
rather than
you know lower intensity steady state
cardio
to an extent that's okay and the the
understanding there is that
when we took we'll look at the different
molecular pathways that are stimulated
by high intensity interval training
they're less at odds with what we're
trying to achieve with strength training
when you compare it to like traditional
aerobic exercise
the problem is if and we've talked about
this on the podcast before as everybody
found out in about 2010
if you just do like nine sessions of hit
per week you're going to die
like you're gonna be so fatigued and
tired you're gonna perform like crap
so you have to strike a balance there
like it's very easy to look at the
molecular pathways and say oh we'll do
the high intensity stuff
but that fails to factor in the fact
that really high intensity stuff
will wreck you especially if you're
lifting several times a week as well
so i think you have to strike a balance
there i usually don't like to see people
doing
unless they really need to more than two
or three
uh cardio bouts per week and i usually
don't like to see more than one or two
of them be high intensity interval
type workouts um but yeah you have to
get in there and and work at an
individual level and figure out
what can we actually accommodate in
terms of recovery and you have to be
really i would err on the side of
caution and say let's get away with as
minimal cardio as we can as the starting
point
and work up from there and see how much
you can do before you start to
really interfere with just overall
fatigue day-to-day
the ability to perform the ability to
recover another thing you can do
is uh separate the training belts out
so there's all these different studies
looking at like which one goes first
right
aerobic training or resistance training
if you're doing them at the same workout
right so if you're gonna go in the gym
and do both which you do first
so the the most recent meta-analysis on
that i forget who the author was
um but there were two groups that
published basically the same
meta-analysis in the same month just in
different journals
yeah both looking at this question and
if memory serves the the order that they
were performed and didn't affect
gains in aerobic performance but
doing the resistance training first was
better for strength and hypertrophy
yeah if you look at the interference
effect
literature um it'd be
really ideal if you could separate those
out into different sessions i think
um so a lot of times they'll say if you
can get away with it do your
your resistance training and your cardio
or aerobic training on separate days
kind of alternate throughout the week um
but but they do say
at minimum it would be nice if you're
really focused on
strength power hypertrophy gains if you
could
ideally give yourself at least a good
three to six hours of separation between
your cardio about and your resistance
training bout
so i mean the more you can separate them
the better
[Music]
but they tend to say at least three to
six hours if separating them is not an
option
and you're interested mostly in strength
and hypertrophy then you're going to do
strength first followed by the cardio
about
and then finally one thing to keep in
mind when you're balancing the overall
volume and frequency of these
workouts is keeping your main goal in
mind so what they recommend
in this particular review which i agree
with is uh
if your main focus is on your resistance
training adaptations
you you probably shouldn't be doing
three cardio bouts for every lifting
bout you have like
the numbers don't make sense there so
you you want to do a ratio of two to one
or three to one
resistance training bouts to cardio
bouts per week
and they say uh you know obviously
that that ratio can get a lot more even
if if the main focus is on
aerobic training but you know a lot of
times you'll see people who their main
focus is resistance training but they're
trying to lean out and they're doing as
many cardio bouts per week as resistance
training bouts
and i think that's probably uh that's
probably going a little
a little too far with the cardio
especially if they're pretty vigorous
bouts
if i can add one thing to this as well
um so this
this is something that's a little bit
more tentative um
and i just kind of i guess discovered it
in the literature um this past month
when i was writing an article from mass
but it kind of seems that
if you are doing concurrent training
that it may be a little bit more
important to
also make sure you're not doing your
your resistance training to failure
so the thing that put me on to this is
there was a paper published last month
uh by carol at all where they had one
group
training to failure not every set to
failure but
every set pretty close to failure and
the last set of every exercise to
failure
and then the other group training
generally about two to six reps shy of
failure
um did that for 10 weeks of memory
serves
and they were also doing two sprint
training sessions per week
and by and large what you see in the
literature if you look at like
the failure versus non-failure stuff is
either more hypertrophy when training to
failure
or similar hypertrophy between the two
conditions
in this paper the group not training to
failure
had significantly larger increases in
anatomical cross-sectional area of the
quads and
non-significant larger differences so so
like kind of leaning in that direction
but p-value not quite below 0.05
for type 1 fiber cross-sectional area
type 2 fiber cross-sectional area
and vastus lateralis thickness as well
so
this is really really kind of the first
study i've seen in that body of
literature
leaning really hard in favor of not
training to failure
and so the interesting thing is they did
have a couple cardio sessions per week
in that study as well
so i went back and looked through the
concurrent training literature to see
the concurrent training studies where
the concurrent training group actually
grew more than the group only doing
resistance training
and i could find four studies two of
them
it's kind of hard to parse they were by
lundberg at all if memory serves
um and the resistance training was uh
isokinetic stuff so it's it's hard to
know exactly how that would apply to um
to just normal isotonic training the
other two though
one was by cassiore at all and one was
by
nicola at all and in both of those
studies
the majority of the training was not
done to failure
so in the casior study i want to say
like 18 out of the 21 training sessions
weren't to failure
and in the mikola study i want to say 14
out of the 21 weeks of training
weren't done to failure which is pretty
cool like 21 week training studies is
pretty long for the literature
um and so both of those studies saw
more hypertrophy when doing concurrent
training
versus only resistance training and in
the carol paper
it saw more hypertrophy so it was two
concurrent training groups but one of
them
wasn't training to failure and they had
more growth than the group training to
failure
so that's notable because for most of
the
of the training literature that's out
there you just have people do resistance
training to failure
because that's a good way to you know
standardize stuff and make sure people
are actually training hard
and not just sandbagging you the whole
time and so
it it's something where
i i guess one could potentially theorize
that rather than an interference effect
maybe it's slightly synergistic
um doing cardio plus non-failure
training
that may be a bit of a stretch but i
think what we can say with
slightly more confidence than that is if
you are doing concurrent training
i think it becomes even more important
for your resistance training to not be
done to failure
um maybe just because the added fatigue
of training to failure when compounded
with
the extra fatigue from the concurrent
training really just digs you into a
bigger hole
and the other thing i'll note which i
don't
think you touched on is that when you
look at the interference effect
literature
it's really only for the lower body so
the studies that have looked at
whether doing like you know running or
cycling
affects hypertrophy you see it with
lower body stuff but not upper body
stuff
yeah so you know if you compete in the
board shorts division and you just need
to look good from the waist up
probably doesn't really matter i think
i would suspect that it doesn't matter
based on the literature we have
i but i i would also caution people who
do
compete in the physique division you
know
board shorts not to get too attached to
like interference effect happens on a
spectrum right yeah yeah
i mean it's clearly something where the
dose makes the poison right yeah so
the thing that always kills me is like
when people are it's like
you're you know
competing in something that is
theoretically based on especially if
you're natural doing physique
the physique uh category you're still
trying to get as big as you can
like there's nobody natural who's like
ah just too big
there's probably like four four physique
competitors out there who are like yeah
i need to i need to chill
but realistically like i i mean
can we just say it like the physique is
like
it was made for the non-tested
federation so people didn't have to have
like
a million grams of test per week yeah
isn't that pretty much the deal
that we're comfortable with yeah so like
in natural like you're still trying to
get big
and the thing that kills me is when
people are dieting hard
and lifting hard and they're doing six
hours of
moderate intensity cardio per week it's
like maybe it's not
the same interference effect that we're
seeing you know the kind of local within
within the particular muscles acting
but your lifting is going to suck yeah
and and another thing to note is the
concurrent training literature we have
isn't also looking at people in big
calorie deficits right
and one just fun little physiology fact
for people out there
is if you're in a big calorie deficit
and
carbs are low as well doing
doing lower body cardio stuff
can cause glycogen depletion in your
upper body
via the wonders of the lactate shuttle
where basically like you can
metabolize carbohydrate into lactate in
like your arms pec shoulders whatever
and then that lactate is
shuttled to your lower body converted
back into carbohydrate and
used for aerobic or anaerobic metabolism
so yeah that that is a good point um
in in the literature it doesn't really
seem like the interference effect really
hits the upper body all that much
assuming you're doing
lower body dominant cardio but yeah it
wouldn't shock me if things changed in
an energy deficit or especially if
you're doing really really high volumes
of cardio